tonight's attacker is sergeant Hall and
this is a training exercise to prepare
troopers for a worst case scenario in
the field like a real-life situation
they use live rounds and these drills
are meant to catch troopers off-guard
all right
surprise you a bit yeah you were
starting to wrestle with me a little bit
probably want some strikes I'm down on
the ground
starting throwing elbows Trevor he comes
up to you over but anyway so let's go
see what your hits look like all right
that's all right it's part of it to do
this about four times a year no matter
what the weather or the conditions these
instinctual reactions can be the
difference between life and death any
questions okay all right let's go ahead
and download the rifles and we're going
place them back in your patrol vehicles
it's time the animal go on with the next
drill
nighttime target practice in below
freezing temperatures is net tonight
troopers will train into the morning
hours to ensure they get it right when
it counts you know to me the way I see
things you can stand out here and shoot
pretty little circles on a target all
day long and it's just it looks nice to
add the stress of what can happen to us
and where officers have been killed in
the past due to not training for it I
can't imagine a more valuable training
than what we're trying to do here and
like I said the whole aspect of this is
to get them off center and then make
them come back to focus as quickly as
possible so they they're ready for the
net for the next time this happens
they've got something to build from